[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas de las semanas
relacionadas con el hobbit 19
soy santiago lópez gonzález bienvenidos
a continuación les presento algunos de
los temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa vamos a hablar de colombia este
país sigue sin tocar techo en el rebrote
de kobe 19 al avance de la pandemia se
suma también la crisis social que
coincide con un aumento exponencial del
número de los casos de contagio un
sistema hospitalario al borde del
colapso con una ocupación de un sí
superior al 84 por ciento y más de
80.000 víctimas mortales también una
vacunación que avanza muy lentamente
asimismo la alcaldesa de la ciudad de
bogotá claudia lópez confirmó que tiene
como 19 veremos los detalles de la
situación en ese país hablaremos también
de eeuu que realizado por dos
importantes anuncios a lo largo de esta
semana el primero que las autoridades
sanitarias autorizaron la vacunación de
adolescentes a nivel nacional esto con
miras a alcanzar ese 70% de la
población inmunizada para el mes de
julio y el segundo anuncio tiene que ver
con quienes ya estén completamente
vacunados que pueden dejar de usar las
mascarillas en ciertas condiciones ya
les explicaremos cuáles son y también
hablaremos de chile que se prepara para
unos comicios de dos días para elegir a
los integrantes de la constituyente que
van a redactar la nueva carta magna de
ese país las elecciones tienen lugar en
medio de restricciones de medidas de
prevención y también un desgaste de la
sociedad debido a la pandemia kobe 19
que persiste también allí en este país y
que sigue presentando altos aumentos a
la par que también aumenta la vacunación
masiva sigue siendo uno de los países
líderes en la región tenemos detalles
desde la ciudad de santiago pero vamos a
comenzar entonces en eeuu ya se los
avanzaba en el sumario allí se mantiene
a toda marcha ese plan de vacunación con
la meta puesta en alcanzar el 70% de la
población vacunada por completo para el
4 de julio que es el día de
independencia de ese país las
autoridades sanitarias de eeuu
anunciaron que todo
aquellas personas que estén
completamente inmunizadas no estarán
obligadas a usar tapabocas en espacios
cerrados las excepciones son en los
hospitales los centros de salud las
residencias de ancianos los aviones y
también los autobuses
este pequeño gesto implicará también
esta nueva realidad los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades
informaron el jueves que las personas
inmunizadas no estarán obligadas a usar
tapabocas en interiores
todo el que esté vacunado por completo
podrá participar en actividades en
interiores y exteriores grandes o
pequeñas sin usar mascarilla o respetar
la distancia física es una más de las
propuestas de las autoridades en su afán
de incentivar a los estadounidenses a
vacunarse incluso se está ofreciendo
vacunas gratis a los turistas debido al
riesgo de caducidad de las dosis y el
costo que implica mantener las
condiciones logísticas para mantenerlas
refrigeradas en nueva york se ofrecen
tiquetes de metro sin costo a todos
aquellos que quieran inocularse el
antídoto y en miami se aplica a todos
los que pasen por el aeropuerto tras
conocer el relajamiento del uso del
tapabocas el presidente joe biden
declaró que es un hito para el país si
bien quiso recalcar que cada ciudadano
es responsable de hacer un uso adecuado
de la medida choice es la elección es
vuestra todos vosotros hacéis que esto
sea posible ahora acabemos el trabajo de
ganar
y hacer que todo vuelva a la normalidad
el uso del tapabocas ha provocado una
polarización en la sociedad
estadounidense alentada por los
comentarios en su contra del
expresidente donald trump en su discurso
va a idem hizo también un llamado a que
esta medida no cause más confrontación y
de su match camps ya hemos tenido
demasiado conflicto demasiada amargura
demasiada ira demasiada polarización por
el uso del tapabocas pese a todo se
sigue recomendando el uso de mascarillas
en medios de transporte colectivos y
seguirá siendo obligatorio en hospitales
o residencias de ancianos debido al
riesgo de contacto para otras personas y
dentro del marco de esta idea de
inmunizar a la mayor cantidad de
personas la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos de eeuu fda
aprobó el uso de las vacunas
desarrolladas por las farmacéuticas
pfizer y variantes en adolescentes de
entre 12 y 15 años veamos
la administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de eeuu dio el visto bueno
inocular las dosis de facer by on tech
en adolescentes a partir de 12 años
abriendo la puerta al regreso a las
escuelas ya que aunque no suelen
contraer síntomas graves
los adolescentes propagan el virus
y sabemos que este es un gran paso para
nuestro país vacunar a una población más
joven nos acerca a la vuelta a la
normalidad y al fin de la pandemia ahora
los padres y tutores pueden estar
seguros de que al tomar nuestra decisión
la agencia llevó a cabo una revisión
rigurosa de todos los datos científicos
se trata de otra medida para hacer
frente a la caída de las vacunaciones
diarias y también a los costos
logísticos que representa mantener las
dosis de las vacunas refrigeradas según
el 'new york times'
el índice de vacunación en los estados
rurales los más vulnerables es más bajo
que en el resto del país esto se debe al
escepticismo entre los ciudadanos que no
quieren administrarse la vacuna estados
como nueva york texas y florida tomaron
otras medidas
la gran manzana se abrirán puntos de
vacunación sin cita previa en varias
estaciones de metro de la ciudad y en
miami la gente que pase por el
aeropuerto podrá inocularse el ejecutivo
de bailén planea invertir millones de
dólares que incentiva en la vacunación y
poder cumplir su promesa de inmunidad de
rebaño antes del 4 de julio día de la
independencia hasta ahora el 45 por
ciento de los estadounidenses ha
recibido al menos una dosis de la vacuna
y seguimos hablando de eeuu porque la
llegada de turistas que buscan vacunarse
está en aumento cada vez más algo que
los gobiernos de las ciudades y también
de los estados están aprovechando para
no desperdiciar excedentes de dosis de
vacunas y también para reactivar la
economía a través del consumo por parte
de los viajeros
para algunos latinos es tan fácil como
tener una visa y montarse en un avión
llegan a eeuu para vacunarse a pesar del
estatus de turista personas de toda
latinoamérica optan por el llamado
turismo de vacunas toman ventaja de una
de las campañas de vacunación más
exitosas y masivas del mundo mientras
sus programas nacionales avanzan a paso
lento pues la verdad me parece muy bien
que tengan la oportunidad de salir al
extranjero
y que les puedan poner la vacuna ya que
si aqui en mexico no hay la oportunidad
quitar
y allá hay allá la gente allá el
gobierno de eeuu le dice a la gente que
se vacunen y la gente pues no van desde
perú aquellos que pueden permitírselo
prefiere no esperar su turno para
inmunizarse algo de lo que han sacado
provecho las agencias de viaje
los viajes de turismo y aprovechar lo de
la bajada ya hace un año que no viajamos
y aprovechamos
y la florida
el 6 de mayo la ciudad de nueva york
anunció que aplicaría la monodosis de
johnson y johnson a turistas en lugares
emblemáticos de la ciudad y en otros
estados del país como florida o texas
los visitantes también pueden recibir
inmunizantes eeuu y ha administrado casi
262 millones de dosis más que duplicando
la cantidad de inoculantes en toda
américa latina
el ejecutivo de vaivén está teniendo
problemas para inmunizar a la población
antes de verano como prometió debido al
escepticismo de muchos ciudadanos
respecto a las vacunas y es que en gran
medida estas dosis o estos excedentes de
dosis de vacunas contra el kobe 19 que
tiene eeuu es porque existe un alto
escepticismo en torno a las vacunas y
también a la pandemia y a la vacunación
por parte de algunos ciudadanos
estadounidenses es por eso que las
autoridades han ideado todo tipo de
estrategias para cautivar a los
ciudadanos
instaron los instan a vacunarse de
cualquier manera por ejemplo el alcalde
de la ciudad de nueva york bill de
blasio anunció que dará papas fritas y
hamburguesas gratis a quienes se
inmunicen también prometió entregar
gratis varios descuentos para las
entradas a las atracciones como el
acuario de la ciudad el zoológico del
bronx y también entregar tiquetes de
metro gratis por su parte el gobernador
del estado de ohio mike de higuain
ofreció a quienes se vacunen dinero
mucho dinero y becas para menores de
edad a través de loterías y sorteos
especiales también en la localidad de
edward en georgia ofreció una tarjeta de
regalo de walmart por 200 dólares una
oferta por tiempo limitado para que la
gente se vacunará lo más rápido posible
también algunas empresas están
considerando dar días libres a cambio de
que sus empleados se vacunen mientras
que algunas empresas también están
ofreciendo bonos en efectivo a cambio de
que sus empleados muestren el
certificado de vacunación en su oficina
de empleados
dejamos este bloque de eeuu cambiamos de
tema en el marco del desarrollo de sus
propias vacunas abdalá y soberana 2
contra el cob y 19 cuba comenzó a
inocular de manera masiva a los
residentes de la habana la capital
cubana como parte de esas pruebas y
también de los ensayos de estas dos
vacunas de otra parte cuba también
registró un nuevo récord de casos de
kobe 19 en llegó cerca a los mil 277
contagios en solamente un día la mayoría
de estos casos están precisamente en la
habana que es la capital y en las
provincias de santiago de cuba y
matanzas
cuba comienza la vacunación masiva y lo
hace con dos vacunas desarrolladas en la
isla abdalá y soberana dos que requieren
tres dosis aunque abdalá acaba de
terminar su tercera fase de ensayos y
soberana 2 lo hará a mediados de mayo es
una noticia esperada por muchos cubanos
que enfrentan el azote del virus y tal
es que yo creo que el cubo entera está
esperando la vacuna yo creo que sí yo
creo que sí y tengo mucho de él
ellos tienen fe en la vacuna y yo
particularmente tengo una funda
confianza en mente en ella yo la estoy
esperando la con operación abierta sin
embargo la inoculación empezará sin la
aprobación de emergencia del centro para
el control estatal de medicamentos
el organismo regulador cubano que se
espera la otorga en junio el gobierno
cree que los beneficios son superiores a
los riesgos desde el ministerio de salud
se estimó que para agosto un 70 por
ciento de la población está inmunizada
pero nosotros pensamos que ya en el mes
de junio tengamos inmunizar 22 6% de la
población en julio 30 y 35 y en agosto
el 70% de esa de esa población
la vacunación comienza con 500.000
trabajadores sanitarios excluye a
menores de edad y es voluntaria como es
el único país de latinoamérica que ha
desarrollado cinco vacunas propias no
obstante hace unos meses está viviendo
un repunte de casos con más de mil
nuevos positivos por quinto día
consecutivo los invito para que
actualicemos las cifras en cuanto al
avance de la vacunación en la región de
américa latina en suramérica ya unos 60
puntos 36 millones de personas han
recibido al menos una dosis de la vacuna
contra el jove y 19 demos un vistazo
entonces algunos países destacados
comenzamos con méxico allí 14 puntos 67
millones de personas ya han recibido una
dosis como lo estaba mencionando en
argentina ya unos 7.91 millones de
personas se han recibido también una
primera dosis colombia llega ya a 4
24 millones de personas pero alcanza 1
punto 53 millones de personas mientras
tanto uruguay ya está rozando el 1 punto
21 millones de personas casi la mitad de
la población de ese país ecuador superó
el millón y lleva 1.07 hace muy poco
superó este millón de personas vacunadas
en esta primera semana y finalmente
bolivia ronda ya las 754 mil 525
personas vacunadas con al menos una
dosis
bueno muy bien está con nosotros el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez para
conversar con nosotros sobre diferentes
temas en relacionados sobre la pandemia
de kobe 19 le recuerdo él es el asesor
científico de france24 epidemiólogo que
se encuentra en la ciudad de bogotá muy
buenas noches doctor pérez como siempre
un gusto saludarlo aquí en kobe 19 la
semana en américa y tengo varios temas
para consultarle el día de hoy
comencemos por esos anuncios hechos en
eeuu la vacunación de los adolescentes
es uno de los primeros países que da una
autorización para inocular a este
segmento de la sociedad esto es
simplemente porque están avanzando muy
rápido en la vacunación allí o porque es
lo que indica simplemente el
procedimiento que toca hacer dentro de
los segmentos de la sociedad
santiago una cosa es que en eeuu se
desarrolló un estudio clínico que
contempló más de 2.000 adolescentes
entre 12 y 15 años y se realizaron las
pruebas y las pruebas mostraron incluso
una eficiencia mejor que lo que serían
los adultos cerca del 97% y con una
seguridad bastante buena por eso y a
raíz de que se documentó con este
estudio clínico es que se hace la
apertura en esta población recuerde mos
que la inmunidad rebaño se logra en el
70% de la población pero eso incluye
también la población de adolescentes y
de niños es decir no solamente es el 70%
de los adultos inea el 70% de todos los
humanos para que logremos la inmunidad
de rebaño y desde luego había que
involucrar a los niños y adolescentes
pero en una fase posterior como se está
haciendo actualmente en eeuu y esperamos
que unos meses en la región doctor y le
pregunto ahora por el segundo anuncio
hecho a lo largo de esta semana en eeuu
las personas que ya tienen las dos dosis
de la vacuna contra el hobbit 19 que ya
están completamente inmunizados pueden
dejar de usar
para bocas en con ciertas condiciones
por ejemplo en los autobuses no ya lo
decíamos en los aviones tampoco en los
hospitales por supuesto tampoco pero
ustedes desde la comunidad médica como
recibe en este anuncio no es muy pronto
es muy probable que sea pronto porque
hay que tener dos cosas en cuenta que
una cosa es inmunizarse y otras voces
vacunas la inmunización celebra después
de dos o tres semanas de haber recibido
las dos dosis pero muchas personas al
recibir una sola vacuna pueden adquirir
el coi o pueden transmitir el hoy es muy
importante que estas medidas que se han
tomado en eeuu se pueden retirar en un
escenario donde tiene una alta cobertura
de vacunación donde están progresando en
la vacunación hacia los adolescentes no
es lo que pasa en la región y así en la
región hayamos completado las dos dosis
no podemos retirar las medidas de
bioseguridad porque somos distintos en
muchas características es probable que
esta decisión esté basada pues en en la
en el poder que tiene la una inmunidad
sin embargo en nosotros tenemos que
tomarlo con cautela
que no son las circunstancias de la
región y estamos a la espera de cómo se
va a tomar esta decisión y que el
comportamiento de tener las próximas
semanas usted doctor menciona la región
y si hacemos un panorama de américa
latina vemos que el tercer pico de
contagio en la región no da traigo a los
países siguen con unos sistemas
hospitalarios al borde del colapso
tratando de avanzar en la vacunación
pero los contagios siguen y la cantidad
de personas enfermas y muertas siguen
aumentando no hay un retroceso en las
cifras
este es un pico que nos va a tomar más
tiempo de lo esperado que es lo que le
está pasando a la región que no puede
mitigar el impacto
nuestra región tiene varios
determinantes uno de ellos es la
fragilidad del sistema de salud
definitivamente nosotros ni siquiera en
este año de pandemia nos preparamos para
estos escenarios lo segundo la
circulación de los linajes que está
demostrada que incrementa la
contagiosidad y también en algunos
países como lo que sucede en colombia en
donde hay unos determinantes de sociales
ya han aumentado la interacción pues
debido a estos disturbios que también
pueden incrementar es muy probable que
esta tercera ola y una de las cosas que
hemos aprendido en la pandemia
uno no puede predecir que se puede cómo
se puede comportar porque los vídeos no
leen no leen decretos no ven los
noticieros no de ley en las estadísticas
los vídeos se comportan de acuerdo a la
dinámica humana y realmente es nuestro
comportamiento el que va a definir
cuánto tiempo éramos en esta parte
definitivamente la única forma es la
vacunación y nosotros tenemos que
mantener una vacunación masiva para
evitar no solamente que pase esta
tercera hora sino que nos lleguen a
actuar
doctor y le preguntó por el caso de
colombia país en el que usted se
encuentra dos semanas de manifestaciones
ciudadanas que son puntos de contagio
pese a que son al aire libre pues las
personas están allí sin tapabocas y sin
respetar el distanciamiento físico está
colombia ante también un tercer pico
mucho más largo de lo esperado porque
tiene otros ingredientes importantes una
vacunación muy lenta estas
manifestaciones y también un sistema de
salud que ya está con una ocupación por
encima del 84% por lo menos hablando en
términos de las ucis
si en colombia sucede en estas
circunstancias estamos en un pico de la
pandemia y hay una explosión social qué
sucede con estas interacciones es
probablemente es probable que las
manifestaciones al aire libre no tengan
mayor repercusión pero las personas
tienen que hidratarse comer reunirse y
ahí es donde vienen las zonas de
contagio o cuando las personas lanzan a
sus hogares y contagian a otros es
probable que se prolongue este pico un
poco más dos o tres semanas de acuerdo a
este comportamiento y definitivamente la
gran crisis es que el sistema
hospitalario está en un límite anterior
cerca a un 90 por ciento que en
cualquier momento se debe abordar por
eso la sensatez que tiene que tener el
país sus dirigentes los manifestantes el
gobierno y todos los actores sociales es
lo único que tiene que hacer para poder
desacelerar los casos y que podamos
reaccionar colombia lo había hecho bien
durante toda esta pandemia pero ahora
estamos viendo que si no lo hacemos bien
pues vamos a colapsar y ojalá eso no sea
así es un caso particular que ya vamos a
tratar también en este programa doctor
pérez muchas gracias por estar con los
gracias por resolver estas dudas y por
aclararnos el panorama en la región
bueno no solamente en la región sino en
el continente americano muchas gracias
pues ya lo decíamos colombia sigue sin
tocar el techo de este rebrote de kobe
19 le hemos venido haciendo el
seguimiento a la situación de este país
porque no tiende a mejorar el avance de
la pandemia se suma entonces también las
condiciones de la crisis social que
coinciden con un aumento exponencial de
los casos un sistema hospitalario al
borde del colapso como lo decíamos que
ya es superior al 84 por ciento de la
ocupación de las ucis a nivel nacional
el número de víctimas por kobe 19 superó
las cifras de las 80.000 personas y cada
vez son más los pacientes jóvenes que se
contagian y que deben recibir asistencia
en los cuidados intensivos también es
destacado a lo largo de esta semana en
colombia el anuncio por parte de la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez que
confirmó que fue diagnosticada con kobe
19 el anuncio lo hizo a través de las
redes sociales veamos
después de muchos cuidados de más de un
año finalmente me ha dado
los médicos me han informado que tengo
una prueba pcr positiva y aunque todos
mis signos vitales están afortunadamente
bien solo tengo un poquito de malestar y
mucho cansancio vamos a profundizar a
analizar en el caso de colombia con
santiago ariztía desde la redacción de
france 24 precisamente allí en bogotá la
capital colombiana hola santiago gracias
por estar con nosotros nuevamente en
kobe 19 la semana en américa y ya
veíamos el caso de claudia lópez la
alcaldesa de bogotá que se suma a esta
lista de mandatarios regionales que se
contagian con kobe 19 cómo está la
situación entonces en la capital y la
situación de salud de la alcaldesa
santiago resulta realmente paradójico
que el anuncio de la mandataria tiene
lugar sólo dos días después de que lópez
con desespero indicará que ya no sabía
qué más decir advertí rogar o incluso
suplicar esto según sus propias palabras
por la grave situación sanitaria en la
capital colombiana la alcaldesa ha
indicado que tiene síntomas leves de
santiago y permanecerán en reposo por
supuesto por recomendación de sus
médicos cabe destacar además que no se
trata del único funcionario público del
gobierno de la ciudad diagnosticado con
kobe 19 recordemos que hace unos cuantos
días luís ernesto gómez el secretario de
gobierno de bogotá mano derecha de la
alcaldesa también fue diagnosticado con
el virus aclaramos que es asintomático y
que está siendo atendido en un hospital
local por presentar algunas dificultades
respiratorias a santiago ante la baja
médica de estados tan importantes cargos
en la administración de bogotá será
entonces el secretario de salud estamos
hablando de alejandro gómez quien ejerza
entonces como alcalde encargado y quien
seguirá haciendo frente a la emergencia
sanitaria y también por supuesto a las
manifestaciones ciudadanas los bloqueos
pero nacional que tiene el país a media
marcha a santiago santiago ya lo
decíamos con el doctor pérez que el caso
colombiano es particular porque cuando
comenzó la crisis social en este país ya
colombia venía haciendo frente con
muchas dificultades al pico de contagio
en las diferentes regiones y persisten
las dos situaciones persiste el paro
persisten las manifestaciones los las
aglomeraciones de la expresión de las
personas y la saturación de las ucis y
también el aumento de los casos esto
pues por supuesto no puede traer más que
consecuencias negativas para el país
bueno el país ya estaba en un nivel muy
crítico en término sanitario por la ola
de contagios que no logra disminuir y
que ya el pasado mes de abril dejó
10.000 muertos pero ahora la crisis
social ha complicado todavía muchísimo
más la situación frente a la pandemia
por supuesto de los efectos de las
concentraciones las aglomeraciones y
respecto al distanciamiento físico y
también ausencia de mascarillas en
algunos casos comienzan a ver se llama
la atención santiago que se está
presentando además un incremento en lo
que es el número de jóvenes contagiados
principalmente en bogotá a la capital
del país
recordemos que buena parte de los
manifestantes son precisamente
estudiantes jóvenes y eso sería un
primer motivo el segundo santiago sería
la migración natural que el virus ha
dado que ya hay un cierto nivel de
vacunación no de personas mayores estos
se infectan menos se enferman de menor
gravedad por ahora son más los jóvenes
entonces los más contagiados en estados
graves o en cuidados intensivos debido
entre otras cosas también a la
irresponsabilidad no de los jóvenes y
porque muchísimos adolescentes creen que
no se contagian
santiago creo que es oportuno para
dimensionar el panorama de la situación
en colombia que hagamos un repaso de las
cifras en cuanto a ocupación de buses
contagiados personas fallecidas para
entender entonces la gravedad de la
situación que se está viviendo allí
bueno colombia es el décimo segundo país
más afectado por la pandemia con más de
3 millones 67 mil casos santiago el país
ya superó los 80 mil fallecidos con
picos de muertes de hasta 500 personas
por día el país también presenta a nivel
nacional una ocupación de las salas de
cuidados intensivos que está llegando al
84 por ciento en bogotá recordemos ha
habido picos de hasta el 94 por ciento
una cifra que se mantiene para el cierre
de la semana los infectólogos que son
consultados por los medios de
comunicación locales y también por las
propias autoridades del país indicaron
que esta ola podría no tener límites
santiago porque después de poco más de
un año de pandemia volver a una
cuarentena estricta es prácticamente
imposible ya y también porque colombia
debería de estar aplicando un promedio
de 300.000 dosis de vacunas diarias esto
en proporción con el nivel de su
población para comenzar a ver un
descenso en la curva de los contagios y
difícilmente el país inocula 200 mil
dosis al día y el plan de vacunación
está haciendo extremadamente lento al
día de hoy sólo han sido administradas
poco más de 7 millones 4
4000 2 y santiago así las cosas habiendo
aglomeraciones apertura social también
recordemos poco autocuidado hay que
decir y una vacunación bastante lenta
están los ingredientes para que el pico
de contagios no se reduzcan el corto
plazo seguimos entonces santiago con la
mirada puesta en colombia la situación
allí no termina no finaliza muchas
gracias por este reporte desde la
redacción de francia 24 y ahora veamos
cuáles son las cifras en cuanto al
avance de la pandemia pero a nivel
global a ver como cerramos esta semana
en el mundo ya hay 162 millones 355 mil
499 casos de contagio de kobe 19 cifra
que por supuesto aumenta minuto a minuto
unas 3 millones 348 mil 241 personas han
perdido la vida en el mundo entero
debido a la pandemia mientras que 1.400
4 millones 978 mil 965 dosis de vacunas
contra el coronavirus han sido
administradas alrededor del mundo los
países más afectados en su orden siguen
siendo
eeuu india brasil francia y turquía
los ciudadanos de chile están convocados
a una jornada electoral de dos días para
elegir a los integrantes de la
constituyente quienes van a redactar esa
nueva carta magna del país nuevamente
chile va entonces a las urnas en medio
de la pandemia de kobe 19 vamos a
conocer entonces detalles cómo se están
preparando para esta forma electoral y
para también conocer que dejaron los
comicios anteriores que van a ser
mejorados para garantizar la seguridad
de los ciudadanos allí está patricia
luna desde santiago patricia cuál es el
panorama general entonces de chile
hablando de contagios vacunados personas
fallecidas para hacer la foto completa
del panorama del país
hola santiago más tarde la situación es
diferente a la que se planteaba en
chile- poco antes de las elecciones
pasadas del 11 de abril que debieron de
ser pospuestas a esta ocasión en ese
momento chile atravesaba la punta más
álgida de la segunda ola de contagios de
coronavirus sin embargo según los datos
ofrecidos por el ministerio de salud el
viernes son 15 las regiones de las 16
que existen en el país que han
presentado un descenso de los gastos en
los últimos 14 días en las regiones que
tienen una mayor incidencia de casos por
cada 100.000 habitantes son en este
momento magallanes en el sur del país el
maule y los lagos también en el sur y
arica en el norte se registró a una
positividad del 9 por ciento a nivel
país y del 11 por ciento en la región
metropolitana donde nos encontramos
también se ha incrementado el número de
personas vacunadas son casi 9 millones
de personas
8.800.000 las que han recibido una
primera dosis aproximadamente un 47 por
ciento de la población chilena total y
más de 7 millones 300 mil personas las
que ya han recibido dos dosis y
completado su vacunación esto es un 39
por ciento de la población chilena en
total y también han sido vacunados
cuando
y las personas que participarán en el
proceso electoral los vocales de mesa
patricia precisamente sobre estas
elecciones que van a tener allí en
chile- qué medidas fueron impuestas por
parte de las autoridades que
restricciones se mantienen de cara a
estos comicios para garantizar la
seguridad y la salubridad de los
ciudadanos
son varias las medidas de seguridad
entre ellos el hecho histórico de que
unas elecciones se celebren en chile en
dos días el sábado y el domingo como una
medida para evitar las aglomeraciones y
las largas filas que vimos en el
plebiscito del pasado mes de octubre las
personas podrán elegir si van a votar
bien el sábado viene el domingo y se
espera que esto espacio la cantidad de
personas que se concentran en el mismo
lugar y se pueda mantener así la
distancia social además todas las
personas deberán de llevar un lápiz azul
consigo como en la anterior ocasión en
el plebiscito para evitar la transmisión
de los contagios y a los vocales de
mesas se le entregarán dos mascarillas
como esta que llevo he puesto la carne
en el 95 por día y también guantes para
contar los votos y además se realizará
sanitización de los lugares esta
elección en dos días tienen un
componente logístico adicional y es que
las urnas deberán de ser custodiadas
durante la noche serán selladas con
sellos especiales y construidas por las
fuerzas armadas y también por población
civil para asegurar
los resultados claro es un procedimiento
necesario teniendo en cuenta que son dos
días lo que van a durar estos comicios
patricia quiero que nos cuente cómo está
el pulso electoral allí lo digo por el
ambiente porque los chilenos van por
segunda vez en medio de la pandemia a
las urnas cómo está el ambiente y el
ánimo de los chilenos para hacer frente
a unas elecciones históricas y también a
una pandemia y qué elecciones dejaron en
términos de salubridad en términos de
seguridad las elecciones anteriores que
van a ser mejoradas para éstas
pues hay mucha incertidumbre sobre estas
selecciones en muchos aspectos
históricas nos encontramos en la plaza
de armas en pleno centro de santiago el
ambiente es de bastante tranquilidad y
también hay mucha gente puesto que hace
poco que se levantó la cuarentena en
esta zona de la ciudad en la gran
incertidumbre es cuántas personas van a
acudir a votar se espera que quizá
descienda un poco la cantidad de
población joven que participó en el
plebiscito del pasado mes de octubre que
fue mucho mayor que las elecciones
anteriores pero al mismo tiempo también
se espera que la población adulta mayor
que no acudió a votar en las elecciones
pasadas por miedo a se contagiarse de el
coronavirus lo haga en esta ocasión
puesto que ya se encuentran vacunados
así que se espera poder alcanzar el 51%
de participación que se alcanzó en el
plebiscito y que en ese momento supuso
un récord de participación en la
historia chilena en cuanto a población
absoluta se espera poder al menos
alcanzar esa cifra pues los chilenos
nuevamente a las urnas en medio de la
pandemia muchas gracias
patricia por este completo reporte desde
la ciudad de santiago y en nuestra
sección en breves veamos otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa comenzamos con esta
publicación de nuestros colegas de radio
francia internacional viajeros de
colombia costa rica y uruguay deberán
respetar una cuarentena obligatoria al
entrar a francia
la medida fue impuesta debido a la
situación sanitaria que tienen esos
países y por este motivo el gobierno
francés impuso entonces 10 días de
cuarentena obligatoria estos países se
unen ya a un listado anterior de otras
12 naciones entre las que están brasil
argentina india y sudáfrica cuyos
viajeros ya estaban sometidos a varias
restricciones
en france 24 punto com tenemos esto
publicado honduras anuncia ayuda de el
salvador para comprar vacunas de china
el ministerio de salud de honduras
indicó que el salvador ayudará a romper
el bloqueo geopolítico para poder
comprar vacunas a china continental dado
que honduras no tiene relación
diplomática con beijing pero si tiene
relación con taiwán las autoridades
hondureñas agradecieron a israel también
por la donación de seis mil dosis de
vacunas de la farmacéutica moderna y a
rusia que también enviará 40 mil dosis
de la vacuna sputnik p
y la tercera de chile el diario la
tercera de chile titula chile uruguay
argentina paraguay y colombia firmarán
una alianza regional para crear un
certificado de vacunación para el cob y
19 en latinoamérica el proyecto es
financiado por el bid y también por la
ms con él se busca lograr la
transformación digital de la salud y que
todos los países cuenten con información
en línea para el intercambio de datos en
cuanto a la vacunación del cobat 19
y con esto llegamos al final de nuestro
programa 5.019 la semana en américa los
espero la próxima semana con otro
resumen de noticias sigan cuidando se la
pandemia sigue el coronavirus sigue
latente en nuestra región feliz día para
todos
[Música]